-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
We're hanging out with
Chloe Fineman!
We love Chloe.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love your impressions.
I really do.
You're one of my favorites
out there.
With that in mind, I wanted to
challenge you to something new.
It's time for "Interview of
Impressions." Here we go.
♪ -Interview of Impressions,
yeah ♪
-Alright, here's how it works,
okay?
We're going to have a normal
conversation with each other,
except every so often we're
going to hear this ding sound.
-Okay.
[ Ding! ]
-And when you hear that,
your impression will change
as we keep talking.
-Okay.
-Is that okay?
-Yeah.
-Okay. Here we go.
I'll start the conversation.
The weather is cooling down,
as we all know.
-Yeah.
[ Ding! ]
-Big fall plans maybe?
-[ as Coolidge ] Oh, I'm gonna
make you a pie, dumbass.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
-Oh, Jennifer. Oh, my goodness.
[ Ding! ]
-[ as Portman ]
Fall is fascinating.
It's like summer.
But then it's colder than
summer. It's bizarre, right?
It's so interesting, like --
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
-It is. It is summer but fall.
Yeah, Natalie,
you are correct, yeah.
-[ as Streep ]
Oh, well, you know, the fall.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh!
Oh, my.
-Wow.
-Jimmy, I love to make a spiced
cider with cardamom and nutmeg.
[ Laughter ]
Star anise.
-Oh, star anise?
-Yeah.
-Meryl Streep likes star anise.
-Yes, yes, you know,
the devil might wear Prada,
but this autumn bottom
wears scarves.
-Oh!
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
I love that.
You wear scarves.
You wear whatever you like.
Yeah.
But, Jennifer, what do you
think of Halloween?
-[ Laughing as Lawrence ]
[ Laughter ]
It was crazy.
-Yeah, it is a little crazy
there, yeah.
Keira, do you prefer Halloween
or jack-o'-lanterns or pumpkins?
-[ as Knightley ]
Very fragile to be here.
[ Laughter ]
Have you ever seen a gourd?
Like, really, truly,
deeply seen a gourd?
-A gourd?
-A gourd.
-A gourd, no.
-Sorry for my dictation.
If my lips touch each other,
I will die.
[ Laughter ]
-I did not know that.
[ Ding! ]
[ Applause ]
-[ Normal voice ] That was
Sudi Green, a Sudi Green joke.
-Well, Elizabeth Holmes, I mean,
you're currently on trial.
I mean, this is --
-[ as Holmes ] Yeah. Yeah.
-What is it --
[ Laughter ]
Are you okay talking about --
being here and talking about --
-I can say what I can, you know.
First, they --
[ Laughter ]
First, they question you.
They challenge you.
-Of course they challenge you
and they question you, yeah.
-And then they put you in prison
for 20 years.
-Yes, that's exactly
what they do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Dinging ]
Oh, my goodness.
This is Chloe Fineman,
by the way.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How do you do all of those?
With the eyes.
Chloe Fineman, amazing!
Check her out on the new season
of "Saturday Night Live"
this weekend with
host Owen Wilson
and musical guest
Kacey Musgraves!